>> Leila Farrer:
Welcome everyone.
So glad that you guys
could join us for Life
of a Poet this evening.
My name is Leila.
I'm on the programming
here at Hill Center.
How many of you guys have--
are here for the first
time this evening?
A couple of you.
Well welcome; we're so glad
that you could join us.
As you may or may not know,
Hill Center does a wide variety
of programming, not only Life of
a Poet with Library of Congress,
but also political talks and
Q and As, cooking classes,
language classes, visual arts,
music, everything under the sun
for children, so please go
online, check out our calendar.
We've got print materials
downstairs as well.
This evening we're here with
Ron Charles and Marilyn Chin
and introducing them
will be Rob Caster--
Casper of the Poetry and
Literature Department
at the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: Thanks everyone.
Thanks Leila.
If you could turn up
Marilyn's just a little bit,
make sure that everybody
can hear you.
Here's my nicely
crumpled little intro.
It's wonderful to have
you all here tonight.
I'm thrilled to kick
off the fifth season
of our Life of a Poet series.
It's hard to believe we've
been doing it for five years.
Thanks to Diana Ingram and
everyone here at the Hill Center
for helping make this
possible, and of course thanks
to Ron Charles for
continuing on with this series.
I feel like-- this
is what I wrote.
I feel like I can't even brag
about Ron's turn
to poetry anymore.
>> Ron Charles: Oh, you can.
>> Rob Casper: But I
can't [laughter], I can't.
Instead I can say
he's become legendary
for his in-depth
conversation with poets here
at the Hill Center over
the last five years.
Leg-- I wanted to say
legend and mean it.
Before I go any further let
me tell you a little bit
about the Poetry and
Literature Center
at the Library of Congress.
We are home to the Poet Laureate
Consultant in Poetry and we put
in programs like this
here at the Hill Center
and at the Library's
Capitol Hill Campus
and around the country.
We'd love to have you come
to more of our programs,
so if you want to
check us out you can go
to www.loc.gov/poetry.
We've also passed out a little
survey that you all should have,
which we'd love to
have you fill out.
You can hand them
to me afterwards;
we'd love to know what
you think of the program.
The rest of the PLC
staff is in the front.
You can hand them
your-- the surveys too;
we'll all be happy to get them.
Today, if you don't know, is
the start of the fiscal year
in terms of the federal
government,
of which we are a part.
And I can't imagine a better
way to start FY19 than to kick
of this year's lope season.
We call it lope in the office.
And I couldn't be more excited
to introduce tonight's
feature poet, Marilyn Chin.
I have heard Marilyn read
only twice and only briefly
at a Brooklyn book party
to celebrate the launch
of her 2014 collection Hard Love
Province, and the year before
when she read as part
of the Poet Laureate,
Natasha Trethewey's closing
event, Necessary Utterance:
Poetry as Cultural Force.
I'll never forget seeing her
up on the Coolage
auditorium stage reading poems
with such necessary
force that it seemed
like they might blow
the speakers.
Hers are poems willing to
face up to death and loss
and also unabashed in
their lyric playfulness.
They can be body and
prophetic and sorrowful,
can dazzle with wild images
and be joyously talking,
can feel steep in history
and form and also charged
with challenges to our moment.
Listening to her then I thought
only I want to hear more.
And luckily here we are.
Please join me in
welcoming Marilyn Chin.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh.
[ Applause ]
>> Ron Charles: Thank
you so much for coming.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh, thank you.
Thank you for loving poetry.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, thank
all of you for coming too.
And if you can't hear at
some time just call out;
it's very informal and
we'll-- we'll adjust.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Can you hear me?
Yeah, okay.
>> Rob Casper: Ron, why
don't you push up your--
>> Ron Charles: Mine
a little more.
Let me put it here.
Okay.
>> Marilyn Chin: I want
to thank Rob for being
such a cheerleader for poetry.
We've got to give him a--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
[ Applause ]
>> Ron Charles: One of
your early poems begins,
beginning is always difficult.
But the beginning of this
conversation doesn't feel
difficult because I've spent all
week in conversation with you
and your work, but it's all
been one way and now I'm
so looking forward to
asking you about this.
I want to start with
this incredible event
that starts early in your
life where your folks move
from Hong Kong to
the United States
and you eventually
settle in Portland.
Why do they do that and
how did you feel about it?
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh
God, I don't know.
I was a child, I
guess I had no--
no power in those decisions.
I was born in Hong Kong in
1955 in a cold water flat,
if you remember those
in colonial Hong Kong.
And there were open
sewers, there were 15 of us
in a small apartment and-- and
it was really-- yeah, and my--
my father was already
in the U.S. He was--
he worked in various
restaurants in what--
what I call piss river Oregon.
Various restaurants
in Portland, Oregon.
And so-- so we came as-- yeah,
the family came shortly after--
af-- yeah, after he-- you
know, he first went to the U.S.
and then-- then he brought my
mother and the family over.
>> Ron Charles: And
how old were you?
>> Marilyn Chin: I
was seven years old.
>> Ron Charles: So, you were--
you knew what was going on.
You-- you--
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah,
I guess so [laughs].
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah yeah.
I was-- and when I
was very young my--
I remember my grandmother
carrying me
on her back in this little--
>> Ron Charles: She came too?
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah,
the whole family came.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
>> Marilyn Chin: And she-- she
used to sing Chinese poems,
she used to chant Chinese poems.
She was-- she was
illiterate but she had a--
a prodigious memory and
she memorized various poems
from the-- from the
Tang dynasty and--
and Confucius sayings and
she was-- she was incredible.
And then she used
to walk, you know,
carry me around on her back.
And so, the very first words I
heard were poetry, yeah, and--
and yeah, and I've loved the--
I've loved poetry
ever since, so.
>> Ron Charles: Did
she speak English?
>> Marilyn Chin: No.
>> Ron Charles: Did you?
>> Ron Charles: Your mother?
>> Marilyn Chin: No.
Nobody spoke English.
>> Ron Charles: How
did that come about?
How did you gradually
learn English?
>> Marilyn Chin: Well
when we immigrated to--
to Portland I started school.
>> Ron Charles: Oh.
>> Marilyn Chin:
That's what ha--
you know, and it's really
interesting how first I,
you know, I changed-- I
changed languages several times
because first I-- I spoke
in the dialect of Taishan
and then I moved-- then I-- then
when we moved to Hong Kong--
when I was born in Hong
Kong, I spoke Cantonese.
And then when I came to the
United States, you know,
I learned English and--
and so it was pretty
much a tri-lingual family
because there were
dialect differences and--
and nobody spoke
English, so, you know,
the children served
as translators.
>> Ron Charles: You
all learned it first
and then brought it
home from school.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
Yeah, we-- yeah, we brought--
but my mother never really,
yeah, learned English,
and my grandmother didn't know
a word of English, yeah, so.
>> Ron Charles: You
say in one piece,
poetry is a vast orphanage.
In another poem you write,
poetry is my nunnery.
Here I am alone in
my alter self-hate,
self-love, both erotic notions.
What led you to write poetry
and why does it sometimes feel
like that a lonely
place sometimes holy,
sometimes bereft?
>> Marilyn Chin: Well, you know,
I think poetry saved
my life in many ways.
I was a very lonely,
quiet child and-- and--
and there was a lot of
inter-generational problems,
as you know you can imagine
in a family like that, and--
and I would-- I would read
a lot of poetry and I--
and a lot of the poetry I
didn't know what they meant.
You know, when I was
younger, I read Shakespeare,
I read Emily Dickenson,
I read, you know--
I read all kinds of poetry and
I didn't know what they meant
but somehow, they soothed
me and the poem soothed me.
And I suppose I learned that
soothing from my grandmother
who used to chant Chinese poetry
with me on her back, therefore--
therefore, yeah, I think
that lone-- you know, I'm--
poets are solitary animals.
We have to-- you know, we-- we
read and write, I mean, that's--
it's very difficult in
that if you're a play write
or if you're a-- yeah, or a--
write for TV you have a lot
of people to work with, right,
but po-- but poets,
we-- we sort of sit--
you know, my favorite
thing to do is to go
to the Harvard-Yenching
Library and read and it's
that solitary-- that solitary
conversation that I have
with the ancients, with the
Tang dynasty poets that--
that, you know, really
warms my heart, so.
Yeah, we're poetry nerds; I
love poetry; we're poetry nerds.
What-- what can I say [laughs]?
>> Ron Charles: What
about your--
how did your family react to
this decision to go into poetry?
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh my gosh,
are you kidding [laughter]?
>> Ron Charles: It's a long way
from becoming an
engineer or a doctor or--
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah, a
doctor, you know, doctor,
lawyer, poet, you know.
Oh my gosh, you know.
Gosh, I guess I had an
old uncle who was crazy
and he lived on--
you know, he was--
>> Ron Charles: You
were following his--
>> Marilyn Chin: The village
idiot, and then he was the poet,
you know, I don't know.
And yeah, but, you know, when
I finally found a teaching job,
you know, they felt
better about that.
But I was always the
weird child anyway.
It was, you know--
>> Ron Charles: Would
you read Poetry Camp,
which I think might
contain some of that?
>> Marilyn Chin: Poetry Camp.
>> Ron Charles: Your
family's frustration.
>> Marilyn Chin: Well this is
pretty-- this is a new sequence,
a prose poem sequence, so
there was a prose-- yeah, okay.
Poetry Camp.
Grandmother, when can
I go to poetry camp?
What in hell is poetry camp?
Where a bunch of
teenage girls go
into the woods to write poetry.
I know what teenage girls do in
the woods and it's not poetry.
[ Laughter ]
You may not go to poetry camp.
You must scrub the soy sauce
off the walls of the restaurant,
then study for the SAT exam.
Grandmother, what if I spurn
you and go to poetry camp?
Then you will shame
your ancestors
with your foolish dreams
and in your vain attempts
to change your destiny
you will trip
and fall off your platform
shoes, break your neck
and amount to nothing.
This is the grandmother
[laughter] how supportive.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah, she is.
>> Ron Charles: That's pretty--
pretty encouraging [laughter].
You write so movingly,
and sometimes very wittily
about the pain of a simulation.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh.
>> Ron Charles: In many poems.
In a short poem called prelude,
dedicated to your mother,
you write, although
the country is lost,
rivers and mountains remain
and we shall always live
in this poetry that you love.
>> Marilyn Chin: That--
that first line is
actually from Du Fu
from the Tang dynasty
poet Du Fu, and it goes
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Which means all-- country--
although the country is lost,
rivers and mountains remain.
It is such an amazing line, you
know, it says all in that one--
in those five characters
and-- and--
and yeah, and I feel that
I've lost many countries,
but rivers and mountains remain.
There's some-- yeah, there is--
>> Ron Charles: And
the poetry remains.
>> Marilyn Chin: The
poetry remains, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: If you'd read
this poem, We're an Ameri--
We're-- We Are Americans Now.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah,
these are early poems;
I wrote them in my 20s.
Okay. He digs up all
this dirt [laughter].
We are Americans now.
We live in the Tundra.
Today in hazy San
Francisco, I face seaward.
Toward China, a giant begonia.
Pink, fragrant, bitten
by verdigris and insects.
I sing her a blue song; even
a Chinese girl gets the blues.
Her reticence is black and blue.
Let's sing about the
extinct Bengal tigers,
about giant pandas.
Ling Ling loves Xing Xing,
yet we will not mate.
We are not impotent, we
are important [laughter].
We blame the environment,
we blame the zoo.
What shall we plant
for the future?
Bamboo, sassafras,
coconut palms?
No. Legumes, wheat, maize,
old swine to milk the new.
We are Americans now.
We live in the Tundra
of the logical,
a sea of cities, a wood of cars.
Farewell my ancestors.
Hirsute Taoist failed scholars,
farewell my wet nurse who feared
and lathed the Catholics
who called out.
Now that the half-men have
occupied Canton hide your
daughters, lock your doors.
They-- well I didn't have
a wet nurse [laughter].
We were too poor to have a wet--
but apparently in that building
women would share their milk,
their breast milk because, you
know, some women had problems,
yeah, with their breast milk.
So yeah, I didn't really-- you
know, we weren't rich enough
to have to-- but I thought wet
nurse is an interesting word,
yeah, it's a--
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, I loved
the way the poem celebrates
America and mocks
it at the same time.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: So.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Yeah, this is when I--
I started to be comedic
here [laughs].
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Yes.
There's a poem about things
you never forget called the
Floral Apron.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh,
students love that poem.
>> Ron Charles: Oh,
I love it too.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Yeah, I don't know--
they always answer, yeah yeah.
Yeah they [inaudible].
It's a-- yeah.
The Floral Apron.
The woman wore a floral
apron around her neck,
that woman from my
mother's village
with a sharp cleaver
in her hand.
She said, what shall
we cook tonight?
Perhaps these six
tiny squid lined
up so perfectly on the block?
She wiped her hand on the apron,
pierced the blade
into the first.
There was no resistance,
no blood,
only cartilage soft
as a child's nose.
A last iota of ink
made us wince.
Suddenly, the aroma of ginger
and scallion fogged our senses,
and we absolved her for
that moment's barbarism.
Then, she, an elder of the
tribe, without formal headdress,
without elegance, deigned
to teach the younger
about the Asian plight.
And although we have travelled
far, we would never forget
that primal lesson on
patience, courage, forbearance,
on how to love squid
despite squid.
[ Laughter ]
How to honor the village,
the tribe, that floral apron.
>> Ron Charles: You
can see why-- oops.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oops, sorry.
>> Ron Charles: It's
just-- it'll be fine.
I think it'll be fine there.
It's just your--
>> Marilyn Chin:
Oh, my-- oh okay.
>> Ron Charles: As long
as it's still working.
>> Marilyn Chin: Okay.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Chin: Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: You can see
why people love that poem.
It's so sensuous, it's
so filled with imagery
of site and touch and smell.
It so captures the things
we do retain forever
from childhood and it's witty.
>> Marilyn Chin:
It's interesting,
the students either say,
ewe, why did you have
to use the image of squid?
But it depends-- it's
really culturally bound.
If you're from Greece
you love squid.
If you're from Hong
Kong you love squid.
>> Ron Charles: Mm-hmm.
>> Marilyn Chin: But if you're
from the Bronx you
might not like squid.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah [laughter].
>> Marilyn Chin: I don't know.
Or maybe-- I don't know.
But-- but, yes, it's
the something
about the kitchen table, you
know, and mother's apron.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Marilyn Chin: And it's what's
interesting about this poem is
that for a time people would
send me their mo-- their aprons.
>> Ron Charles: Oh wow.
>> Marilyn Chin: You
know, because I read--
I read this, it was Bill Moyers,
you know, introduced this poem
in his PBS-- you remember
his PBS special and--
and I got all these
aprons from women.
>> Ron Charles: Funny.
>> Marilyn Chin: And-- and yeah,
everybody remembers
their mother's kitchens.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: You know,
I think that's why this poem
is personal and universal.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
Exactly.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
Peculiar and-- and
universal at the same time.
A longer poem called How I Got
That Name, much anthologized.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah, yeah.
It is just-- it's one of those
poems, if I don't read it,
Rob would have a fit [laughter].
You know, if I don't
read it at--
or somebody would say you got
to-- you got to read this.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Well I've
been working up to it here.
Is it in that-- is it in
that collection, number four?
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Chin: Should
I read the whole thing?
>> Ron Charles: If
you don't mind.
It is long, but I
think it's so--
it's so good and it
deals with so many
of your most essential themes.
>> Marilyn Chin: I
usually-- okay, I--
>> Ron Charles: Here it is.
>> Marilyn Chin: I-- I
usually perform this one.
>> Ron Charles: Oh.
>> Marilyn Chin: So-- so I--
okay, I usually perform
this one.
I-- it's called How I Got That
Name: An Essay on Assimilation.
>> Ron Charles: Do you need it?
>> Marilyn Chin: I am
Marilyn Mei Ling Chin Oh,
how I love the resoluteness
of that first person singular,
followed by that
stalwart indicative of be,
without the uncertain
i-n-g of becoming.
Of course, the name had
been changed somewhere
between Angel Island
and the sea,
when my father the paper son
in the late 1950s obsessed
with a bombshell blonde
transliterated Mei Ling
to Marilyn.
And nobody dared question
his initial impulse,
for we all know lust
drove men to greatness,
not goodness, not decency.
And there I was, a
wayward pink baby,
named after some tragic
white woman swollen
with gin and Nembutal.
My mother couldn't pronounce
the r. She dubbed me Numba one
female offshoot for brevity,
henceforth, she will live
and die in sublime ignorance,
flanked by loving
children, the kitchen deity.
while my father dithers, a
tomcat in Hong Kong trash,
a gambler, a petty
thug, who bought a chain
of chop suey joints
in Piss River, Oregon,
with bootlegged Gucci cash.
Nobody dared question his
integrity given his nice,
devout daughters and his
bright, industrious sons,
as if filial piety
were the standard
by which all earthly
men are measured.
Oh, how trustworthy our
daughters, how thrifty our sons.
How we've managed to fool
the experts in education,
statistic and demography.
We're not very creative but
not adverse to rote-learning,
rote-learning, rote-learning.
Indeed, they can use us.
But the model minority
is a tease.
We know you are watching and
we refuse to give you any.
Oh, bamboo shoots,
bamboo shoots.
The further west we
go, we'll hit east.
The deeper down we
dig, we'll find China.
History has turned its stomach
on a black polluted beach
where life doesn't hinge on
that red, red wheelbarrow,
but whether or not our new
lover in the final episode
of Santa Barbara will lean
over a scented candle
and call us a bitch.
Oh Lord, where have
we gone wrong?
We have no inner resources.
Then, one redolent spring
morning the Great Patriarch Chin
peered down from his
kiosk in heaven and saw
that his descendants were ugly.
One had a squarish head and
a nose without a bridge.
Another's profile, long
and knobbed as a gourd.
A third, the sad, brutish
one, may never, never marry.
And I, his least favorite, not
quite boiled, not quite cooked,
a plump pomfret simmering in my
juices, too listless to fight
for my people's destiny.
To kill without resistance is
not slaughter, says the proverb.
So, I wait for imminent death.
The fact that this death is
also metaphorical is testament
to my lethargy.
So here lies Marilyn Mei
Ling Chin, married once,
twice to so-and-so,
a Lee and a Wong,
daughter of the virtuous
Yuet Kuen Wong
and G.G. Chin the infamous.
Sister of a dozen,
cousin of a million,
survived by everybody
and forgotten by all.
She was neither black nor white,
neither cherished
nor vanquished,
just another squatter in her own
bamboo grove minding her poetry,
when one day heaven was
unmerciful, and a chasm opened
where she stood, like the
jowls of a mighty white whale,
or the maul of a
metaphysical Godzilla,
it swallowed her whole.
She did not flinch nor writhe,
nor fret about the afterlife,
but stayed solid as wood,
happily a little gnawed,
tattered, mesmerized by all
that was lavished upon her
and all that was taken away.
>> Ron Charles: Wow.
[ Applause ]
>> Marilyn Chin: So.
>> Ron Charles: That's
fantastic.
>> Marilyn Chin: I
had to read this one
for Rob and for you, my dear.
>> Ron Charles: My gosh.
That is your song
of myself, isn't it?
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah, it is a-- yeah,
a song of myself.
I mean, if you're a short
little Chinese poet and you need
to insert yourself into the
poetry world how shall I do this
and I shall do it with as loud
as forcefully as possible.
>> Ron Charles: And yeah,
some of us I heard gasping
were touching references
to other poems in there.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh yes.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
Yeah.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yes, of course.
>> Ron Charles: And
some TV shows.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Yeah [laughter].
>> Ron Charles: It's
comic and tragic
to have your identity just sort
of casually remade after some,
as you say, tragic white
woman, swollen with gin.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: You never
changed your name back
when you could have.
>> Marilyn Chin: Well,
you know, because--
you know, a Mei Ling
appears in my--
in my fiction and appears in the
poetry as an alter ego, but--
but, you know, I don't know,
because are there
many women named--
are you naming your
kids Marilyn these days?
It's really-- yeah, what
happened to that name.
I think it's kind of an
interesting name actually.
Yeah, my father was like-- oh he
was-- he was a rake, so trans--
he translated literally
Mei Ling to Marilyn.
And then my sister's
name was Mei Jun
and he named her Jane
after Jane Mansfield.
[ Laughter ]
So, talking about
bombshell blondes.
I mean-- I mean it's-- yeah
that's-- that's another story.
But-- but yeah, those--
>> Ron Charles: Twice in that
poem you say no one dared
question him.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: You
obviously questioned him.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh yes, yes.
He-- you know, I
am very rebellious
because of my father, yeah.
So-- so-- so yeah.
But the name, I like the name
Marilyn Chin I guess, yeah.
Mei Ling. You know, at first,
I started with Marilyn Mei Ling
Chin, and it's a little long.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Marilyn Chin: And
makes Mei Ling look
like an afterthought, right.
>> Ron Charles: Oh yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah,
like a translate--
yeah, ladies or something
like that, so yeah.
>> Ron Charles: You
say in that poem
that all was lavished upon her
and all that was taken away.
>> Marilyn Chin: That's right.
I mean that's how we feel about
our li-- they-- we're all temp--
temporary here, right.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: And I feel--
I, you know, I feel very
blessed to have all I have.
You know, I was born in a
cold water flat and, you know,
I was one of-- one
of many young--
you know, small little girls
born in that flat and in
that building and, you know, I
remember the story about this--
this, you know, uncle who
looked at me and said,
oh she's so small and dark,
maybe we should sell her.
I mean that-- that was
supposed to be a joke.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: But, you know,
and so I feel so fortunate
to be able to write poetry to
be able to express myself to be
in this world to
celebrate poetry.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: I mean
how-- how great is that?
>> Ron Charles: It is.
>> Marilyn Chin: So.
>> Ron Charles: And that poem
is very raw and very funny,
but there's another
one that deals with one
of the same themes called
That Half is Almost Gone.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh.
>> Ron Charles: Which is not
funny; it's really very sad.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
Actually, I-- you
know, I try to be funny
because I'm a deeply depressed
person, can't you tell.
>> Ron Charles: No,
we cannot tell.
>> Marilyn Chin: That
Half is Almost Gone.
That half is almost gone, the
Chinese half, the fair side
of a peach, darkened
by the knife of time,
fades like a cruel sun.
In my 30th year I wrote
a letter to my mother.
I had forgotten the
character for love.
I remember vaguely
the radical heart.
The ancestors won't fail
to remind you the vital
and vestigial organs where
the emotions come from.
But the rest is fading.
A dash dissects in midair.
Ai, ai, ai, ai, more
of a cry than a sigh
and no help from
the pheneticist.
You are a Chinese; my
mother was adamant.
You are a Chinese, my
mother less convinced.
Are you not Chinese, my
mother now accepting?
As a cataract clouds her vision,
and her third daughter marries
a Protestant West Virginian,
who is very handsome
and very kind,
the mystery is still unsolved.
The landscape looms over man.
And the gaffer-hatted fishmonger
sings to his cormorant.
And the maiden behind the
curtain is somebody's courtesan,
or, merely Rose Wong's
aging daughter pondering the
blue void.
You are a Chinese,
said my mother
who once walked the
fields of her dead.
Today, on the 36th
anniversary of my birth,
I have problems now even
with the salutation.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah. This is a nice audience.
>> Ron Charles: It's such a
beautiful and heroing image
of not being able to
remember the word for love
when you're talking to your mom.
>> Marilyn Chin: Well the
character, you know, I--
so I'm playing with
homophony here.
Ai, ai, ai, ai is a cry when,
you know a Chin-- when Chin--
yeah, it's a cry, but it's
homophonous with ai image love.
And so-- so, you know, I--
yeah, so it's a pun there,
and also a visual pun because
a slash goes through the heart,
the-- yeah, the character,
the ideogram
of heart there's a
slash that goes right--
right through that character.
So, I'm playing with the
pictograph, and also playing
with the sound of-- of
that character for love.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Marilyn Chin: So, this--
there's all, you know,
all that stuff going on.
And when you look at
the poem, the left--
the left side, you know, the
half-- when I write the line,
that half is almost
gone, there's a break
to the next line,
the Chinese half.
So visually you, from the
very first line you see the,
you know, the despair,
you see that cut.
And so, I was playing vis-- with
the visual aspects of the poem
and a sonnet-- the sonic
aspects of the poem.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Marilyn Chin: And pondering
the blue void, I tried--
you know, I tried to give it
space, that, you know, line.
So, when you have it-- so when
you read it you-- you have--
yeah, there's all this play
with the page, the space,
the space and everything.
Yeah, that's-- and it's--
it's really amazing how
much Chinese I've lost.
You know, I-- when
I go to Beijing
or Hong Kong I can
barely speak to people.
It's just, you know,
it's so easy.
I remember, I think it
was around sixth grade,
which English completely
took over
and I started dreaming
in English.
Then I realized it took over
my other half, you know.
And-- and I don't
know, bilingual--
any of you bilingual, you--
I don't know, I have friends
who are perfectly bilingual
but I-- you know, I just-- I--
yeah, I think I'm only 80%--
I'm only 20% now [laughs].
>> Ron Charles: And so, losing
the language becomes combined
with losing the culture,
losing your ancestors;
it's losing all kinds
of complicated things
that are wound together
in that poem.
In another poem you write,
my loss is your loss.
A dialect here, a memory there.
If my left hand is dying will
my right hand cut it off?
We should all be vesicle
organs, the gift of democracy,
the pale faces, the wan
conformity, the price we pay
for comfort is our
mother tongue.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yes,
it's-- it is very sad.
I-- I morn this all--
yeah, all the time.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Chin: But--
>> Ron Charles: It's the
essential American story,
is that if you come here--
>> Marilyn Chin:
Yeah, it's-- yes.
>> Ron Charles: You're
blessed with freedom and riches
and you lose this rich heritage.
>> Marilyn Chin: That's
right, and then-- and yeah--
I think now there's, you know,
there's this new identity thing
now in which poets want to write
about their-- their
id-- yeah, identity now.
But I think, yeah, it is
a problem of assimilation.
It is-- and it's
hard work to try to--
try to keep yourself bilin--
you know, to keep bilingual,
I mean it's very hard work
and to keep the culture, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Right,
particularly
when you're struggling to
assimilate at the same time.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
Yes. And as a teenager you
want to be like everybody,
you want to conform, you want
to be like everybody else.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Marilyn Chin: You don't
want to be different, but.
>> Ron Charles: Identity
poem number 99.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Oh, you're talking
about identity, [laughs] okay.
Ron Charles, he is
digging into these--
these poems I haven't
read for years.
Okay.
>> Ron Charles: Now there
aren't 98 other identity poems
are there?
>> Marilyn Chin: Well, you
know, I'm just, you know,
trying to be-- yeah, not--
well I've written a
lot of identity poems.
Some of them like are
still in the drawer, right.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
But the word-- the number 99
there was meant ironically.
>> Marilyn Chin: No, yeah yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Identity poem 99.
Are you the sky or the
allegory for loneliness?
Are you the only Chinese
restaurant in Roseburg, Oregon,
a half-breed war orphan,
adopted by proper Christians,
a heathen poi dog, a
creamy half-and-half?
Are you a dingy vinyl address
book, a wrist without a corsage?
Are you baby's breath faced down
on a teenage road in America?
Are you earphones,
detached, left dangling
on an airplane jack to diaspora?
Are you doomed to a
childhood without music,
weary of your granny's
one-string,
woe-be-gone erhu
mewling about the past?
Are you hate speech
or are you a lullaby?
Anecdotes requiring footnotes,
an ethnic joke rehashed?
How many Chinamen does
it take to screw--
how many Chinamen does it
take to screw a lightbulb?
Are you so poor that you
cannot call your mother?
You have less than two
dollars on your phone-card
and it's a long cable
to Nirvana.
Are you a skylight through
which the busgirl sees heaven?
A chopping block stained by the
blood of ten thousand innocents,
which daily, the same
busgirl must wipe off.
Does existence preempt essence,
I being what my ancestors
were not?
Suddenly, you're a
vegan vegetarian.
Restaurant is a facticity
and getting the hell
out is transcendence.
Was the punch line incandescent?
Was a nosebleed your last
tender memory of her?
Did he say no dogs
and China women?
Are you a rose or
a tattoo of fire?
[ Applause ]
Well I haven't read this
one for a while Ron Charles.
>> Ron Charles: It's-- it's
such a powerful recitation
and denunciation of all
of those horrible slurs
that you turn each one.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Yeah, that's-- yeah.
There was that ethnic joke.
I mean there was-- there's
these jokes you hear
or these slurs you hear in
your childhood and I-- yeah.
>> Ron Charles: And all these
clichs about who you are,
who you can be as we're
trying, you know, slot everyone
into the identities we
expect them-- of them.
This becomes more complex
when you start dating.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: And
falling in love.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Not with
other Chinese people,
much to your parents' horror.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah
that's right [laughs].
>> Ron Charles: I love him.
I hate him.
I don't know how.
I'm bi-racial.
I'm torn in two, you
write in one poem.
He is so fair you can see the
Thames pulsing in his temples.
So fair, he blanched the
skies of the suburbs.
You love him anyway.
His beauty is all you know.
So fair you imagine
sewing his grey children.
In a parking lot you say to
Margarete, why must I yearn
for his bland porridge.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marilyn Chin: That's called
weaponizing your images.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ron Charles: I want
you to read one stanza
from the end of this poem.
Oh, where's number nine?
Oh, must be in my lap.
Would you start here?
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh, okay.
>> Ron Charles: And
read to there.
This is your mother reacting
to a young man you
brought home, I think.
>> Marilyn Chin: Okay.
So, you've come home finally
with your new boyfriend.
What's his name?
Ezekiel. Odd name for a boy.
Your mother can't pronounce it
and she doesn't like
his demeanor.
Too thin, too sallow.
He does not eat beef in a
country where beef is possible.
He cannot play the
violin in a country
where rapture is possible.
He means a tawdry smile, perhaps
he is hiding bad intentions.
And that moon, which
accompanied his arrival,
that moon won't drink
and is shaped haughtily
like a woman's severed ear.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ron Charles: You
didn't marry him, did you?
>> Marilyn Chin: No [laughter].
Oh boy, but I dated lots
of creeps [laughter].
>> Ron Charles: We're going
to stand up, and turn around
and sit back down, just
so they can, you know--
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh, get--
>> Ron Charles: They've
been listening very hard.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh
okay, they're okay.
Let's--
>> Ron Charles: Come
on, stand up.
You stand up.
>> Marilyn Chin: Okay.
>> Ron Charles: This isn't
an intermission though,
we're just standing up.
Now we're going to
sit back down.
>> Marilyn Chin: That's great.
>> Ron Charles: Now let's keep
talking about your mother,
she's such a character in
these-- in these poems.
In a poem called Alba you speak
of your mother as the moon.
It's another beautiful poem.
>> Marilyn Chin: Actually--
actually, my mother was
a very sad character.
I mean I felt that-- that I need
to avenge my mother's death.
I feel that my father ruined
her life, so that's-- that's--
basically, that's why I write
poetry, to avenge my mother.
Yeah, so.
>> Ron Charles: You
should read that poem.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh yeah.
Take a left at the
waters of Samsara.
Do you know this--
what Samsara is?
It's a cycle, yeah, of-- it's a,
yeah, cycle of life and death.
It's reincarnation
to life, yeah,
a continuous reincarnation.
There is a bog of sacred
water behind a hedgerow
of wild madder, near the
grave of my good mother.
Tin cans blossom there.
The rust shimmers like amber,
a diorama of green gnats
ecstatic in their veil dance.
A nation of frogs regale,
swell-throated, bass-toned.
One belts and rages,
the others follow.
They fuck blissfully, trapped
in their cycle of rebirth,
transient love, unprepared
for higher ground.
And I, my mother's aging
girl, myopic, goat-footed,
got snagged on an
unmarked trail.
The road diverged; I took
the one less traveled blah,
blah [laughter].
You know what I'm referring
to in that line, right?
I sit at her grave for hours; a
slow drizzle purifies my flesh.
I still yearn for her
womb and can't detach.
I chant new poems,
my best fascicle.
Stupid pupil, the truth
is an oxymoron and exact.
Eternity can't be
proven to the dead.
What is the void
but motherlessness?
The song bellies up.
The sun taketh.
The rain ceases to bless.
[ Applause ]
>> Ron Charles: I still yearn
for her womb and can't detach.
What-- what was the source
of your mother's unhappiness?
>> Marilyn Chin: My father.
Didn't I say he was a rake?
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
And her situation was not
uncommon, you suggest.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Many
women suffered
like from those situations.
>> Marilyn Chin: And-- and she--
she stopped eating
and died at 62.
She just, you know,
didn't want to live.
So, she was-- but she
was such a good woman.
She was ver-- a very
important role model.
She was ethic-- you know, she
was ethical; she was so pure,
she was pure-hearted, yeah.
Well that part-- you know,
interesting about these poems
you've chosen, that poem I--
I reread it the other day and
I felt it was a perfect poem,
that there's something about
the lines and how-- how the--
they were carved, and
yeah, I couldn't--
yeah, I couldn't change
a thing in that poem,
I mean there's something about
precision and I learned from,
you know, from Chinese poetries,
the precis-- yeah the precis--
the precision of the line,
the precision of the imagery.
>> Ron Charles: Talk about that
because the language
just seems so different.
>> Marilyn Chin: You felt that--
you feel that the
language is different?
>> Ron Charles: The
languages seem so different
in their construction.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah, the--
>> Ron Charles: How do you--
how do you translate that lesson
of precision from
Chinese into English?
>> Marilyn Chin: The-- you
know, Chinese-- I stud-- for--
my undergraduate degree
was in Chinese poetry
and I studied the Chinese
poem deeply and heavily,
you know, I was really into it.
I was such a nerd, right.
But, you know, the Chi--
classical Chinese poetry there's
no inflection or morphology.
You-- I mean there-- there--
you know, there are no tenses,
you know, no-- and, you
know, lack of case tense.
I mean, and some poems there
aren't verbs, you know.
I mean, I-- it's-- it's
so concise and precise
and the imagery is so
precise that I try to bring
that into the, you
know, my English poet--
my writing, and t hat's,
I think-- I think that's--
that's why I've been developing
a Chinese-American esthetics,
a Chinese-American quatrain,
a Chinese-American poem,
where I borrow from
the ancient Chinese--
Chinese poetry and
try to bring--
bring that precision into
the, you know, my-- so--
you know, some of my poems.
Now I write different kinds of
poems; I write long line poems
and talky poems and-- and I--
you know, some poems
shout at you, but--
but some poems are really
influenced by Chinese poetry,
and so-- so, yeah,
I just-- it's--
it's a wonderful
puzzle for me too,
to try to bring Chinese
poetry into, you know,
into the western world.
>> Ron Charles: It is--
it is wonderful for us.
Here is a poem that
captures, I imagine,
what your mother went through,
but what so many
women go through.
>> Marilyn Chin:
Which-- which one?
>> Ron Charles: This side here.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh, this one.
Ron Charles [laughter].
Okay, I'm--
>> Ron Charles: You should
have told me what poems not
to ask you to read [laughter].
>> Marilyn Chin: Okay.
This one is called
Variations on an Ancient Theme:
The Drunken Husband,
right, and this--
okay, these are written
in octaves and fashioned
after Du Fu's octaves, his--
his [inaudible], I just--
okay, I won't get into the geeky
information regarding that form,
but-- but there's also
there's these folk songs,
these ancient folk songs that--
that talk about drunken
husbands.
They would come home,
these drunken husbands
would come home and--
and of course the woman would--
would wait for him in her
finest, you know, outfits
and she would forgive him for--
you know, after he's you know,
come home from the brothel.
Of course, these
poems were written
by men, right, so-- so yeah.
So, I talk back to those
poets and-- and so--
and there's a dog that
goes through these--
this poem, and in Chinese
poetry there's often this bark,
this dog that is-- that he--
often the harbinger of
good luck, of good news.
But in-- in this sequence he's
a harbinger of bad news and--
and this is my-- one of my issue
poems about domestic violence,
so, and these are
different vignettes of--
these are vignettes
of different--
different situations,
different families.
Variations on an Ancient
Theme: The Drunken Husband.
The dog is barking at the door.
Daddy crashed the car.
Hush, kids, go to your room.
Don't come out until it's over.
He stumbles in the
dim lit stairs,
drops his Levi's to his ankles.
Touch me and I'll
kill you she says,
pointing a revolver at his head.
The dog is barking at the door.
She doesn't recognize
the master.
She sniffs his guilty crotch,
positioned to bite it off.
Jesus, control your dog.
A man can't come
back to his castle.
Kill him, Ling Ling, she sobs,
curlers bobbing on
her shoulders.
The dog is barking at the door.
Quiet, Spot, let's not wake her.
The bourbon is sour
on his breath.
Lipstick on his proverbial
collar.
He turns on the computer
in the den.
He calms the dog with a bone.
Upstairs she sleeps,
facing the wall,
dreaming about the
perfume river.
The dog is barking at the door.
He stumbles in swinging.
Where is my gook of a wife?
Where are my half-breed
monsters?
There is silence
up the cold stairs.
No movement, no answer.
The drawers are open
like graves.
The closets agape
to the rafters.
The dog is barking at the door.
He stumbles in singing.
How is my teenage bride?
How is my mail-order darling?
Perhaps she's pretending
to be asleep,
waiting for her man's hard cock.
He enters her from behind.
Her sobbing does not deter him.
The dog is barking at the door.
What does the proud beast know?
Who is both master and intruder?
Whose bloody handprint
on the wall?
Whose revolver in
the dishwasher?
The neighbors won't
heed her alarm.
She keeps barking, barking,
bent on saving their kind.
I-- I think domestic
violence will do us in.
We just--
>> Ron Charles: That's
a devastating poem.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah, it's--
>> Ron Charles: And
you say that it--
you've borrowed from a Chinese
form, and even a Chinese theme,
so it's not just a translation,
it's a transformation
of that form.
>> Marilyn Chin: That's
a-- yeah, that's a good--
>> Ron Charles: Into a very
different kind of poem.
>> Marilyn Chin: Right, right.
I-- I used-- I used the formal
base, but then I bring in,
you know, contemporary
themes and ideas and issues.
I just-- I see myself as an
activist poet and I write
about the issues of the day.
And also, it's per-- it's
personal, it's political
and my family is just filled
with -- with strife and--
yeah, and therefore
I feel like I must--
I must write about-- about it.
>> Ron Charles: What's
so chilling is, you know,
each of those, are
they quatrain?
>> Marilyn Chin:
They're octaves, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Octaves.
Each of them is parallel,
each of them very similar,
but each of them different,
in different cultures
at different times, obviously,
but it's essentially the same
story over and over again.
>> Marilyn Chin: Right.
>> Ron Charles: It
reminds me, of course,
of Dr. Ford's testimony when
women all over the country said,
yes, that's exactly-- even
people in my own family told me,
yes, that's exactly what
happened to me at a party.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Everyone's
had this happen apparently.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yes, and--
and women's issue-- I mean--
I mean I wrote this poem, what
20 years ago and it's, you know,
and the theme-- it's universal.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: We're still
suffering from, you know,
from domestic vi--
from violence.
>> Ron Charles: And
the denial of it.
>> Marilyn Chin:
And denial, yes.
>> Ron Charles: That's
all part of it.
It's acting like it never
happens or being surprised.
>> Marilyn Chin:
And-- and, yeah.
So, yeah, that's--
that's why these--
you know, certain poems live on.
You know, they're-- they're
un-- they're universal.
>> Ron Charles: Every
Woman Is Her Own Chimera.
That's a very different kind
of feminist poem, right.
Where is that?
Number 16.
>> Marilyn Chin: I wrote
this poem for Adrienne Rich.
Did you know Adrienne Rich?
Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: I-- I
can't have you read the--
we won't get through
the whole thing
but just you'll see
when to stop.
>> Marilyn Chin: You
want-- should I read this?
>> Ron Charles: I've
got a little mark
on the other side, next page.
>> Marilyn Chin:
I-- I stop here?
I read--
>> Ron Charles: Yes please.
>> Marilyn Chin: Okay.
>> Ron Charles: Thank you.
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah, I wrote
this suite for Adrienne Rich.
Every Woman is Her Own Chimera.
Every woman is her own chimera.
Today she is laughing
with Julio.
Tonight, she is dancing
with Coolio.
How long can happiness last?
For a slow brief afternoon,
my head on the thigh
of a Sequoia, reading Wang Wei.
Butterfly in mouth,
but don't bite down.
Whose life is it anyway?
She born of chrysalis and shit
or she born of woman and pain?
Mei Ling brings a
wounded poem, cry--
crying, please, mommy,
mommy fix it.
You wipe the tears
from her cheek,
then glue a gnat's torn wing.
The sand dab flicks her tail.
The tears of the
wombat are green.
Kiss me against the
last hydrangea.
Comrades, we are not yet free.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Women aren't
just victims in your poems.
They push back.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh yeah, they
talk back, they push back.
>> Ron Charles: They fight back.
>> Marilyn Chin:
They fight back.
>> Ron Charles: They-- what
they say about a woman at 45;
too late to live, too
soon to die [laughter].
My wine is bittersweet,
my song is rye.
You go on to talk about
other parts of your body,
which I will not read.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marilyn Chin: Yeah,
he's afraid of the c word
and the v word he's
afraid of [laughter].
>> Ron Charles: But
it is very funny.
It's a very funny poem.
>> Marilyn Chin: There's a v
word, okay, and a c word, okay.
>> Ron Charles: In the afterward
to the Phoenix Gone you write
I have not been rehabilitated
in middle age.
In fact, I want to reassure
my friends that I am as feisty
as ever, which we've
clearly seen.
I am still very much an activist
poet who believes in my work,
my life work, to infuse my art
with three powers; to inspire,
to illuminate, and to liberate.
How does poetry do those things?
>> Marilyn Chin:
Oh, as Oden says,
poetry makes nothing
happen, right [laughter].
Well it's-- it's important
that the poet believes that,
you know, she can
do these things.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: It's
important for the poet to--
to have this grand scheme
of-- you know, of things.
I don't know.
This is-- this-- I just retired
from my full-time teaching job.
I'm going to, you know, run
around the country and talk
about poetry and-- and
bring the good news,
present the good news, and
it's-- it's important, I think.
>> Ron Charles: Your poems do
that, but they also push back
at our temptation to speak in
a grandiose way about poetry.
>> Marilyn Chin: Right, right.
>> Ron Charles: Several
witty lines here.
The poet guards the
conscious of society.
No, you're wrong [laughter].
She stands lonely on that hill
like observing the pastures.
Later you say, I do hate my
loneliness, sitting cross-legged
in my room, satisfied
with a few off rhymes,
sending off precious haiku
to some inconspicuous
journal named Lev Leaning
Bamboo [laughter].
It's such a great
satire of the poet.
And finally, how could we write
poetry in a time like this,
a discipline that makes so
much ado about so little.
Willfully laconic, deceptively
disguised as a love poem.
I mean you implicitly
challenge poetry,
not to claim more
than it can do.
>> Marilyn Chin: Right, right.
And-- well I-- but I
still love the genre.
>> Ron Charles: Oh yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: You know,
it's the genre that's closest
to our hearts, when
you're sad and lonely
and angry you write a
little poem, you know,
you write poems, you know.
And so, yeah, yeah.
I just-- well, you know, a
poet, we're-- we're the--
we're the step-children
of literature, aren't we?
>> Ron Charles: No.
No. You're the queens and kings.
[ Laughter ]
Look at you laughing.
There's a wonderful tribute poem
here I want you to read the--
the first part, and
this will be the end.
>> Marilyn Chin: I read here?
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Marilyn Chin: Okay.
This-- I wrote this
for my friend,
the activist poet,
Mitsuye Yamada.
Do you-- any of-- yeah, I wrote
it for her 90th birthday and--
>> Ron Charles: She's
still alive.
>> Marilyn Chin: She's
still alive, she's 93,
and she calls me and says
when are you going to come
and visit me, I might
not have long, you know,
I might have another year.
And so, it's-- she's
really great.
But she's-- she was
one of the fir--
you know, first Asian-American
poets that I read and her--
and her father was
inturned, you know, she was--
you know, was taken away
to an internment camp.
For Mitsuye Yamada
on her 90th birthday.
They say we bitch
revolutionaries never go
out of fashion.
Look how fashionable
I am [laughter].
Wearing floppy hats
and huge wedgy shoes.
A feather bandolera
and a lethal python.
Sometimes we wear a fro perm
cause we hate our straight hair.
Sometimes we wear it straight
to the ankles like Murasaki.
I bleached mine purple to
look like Kwannon Psylocke.
Maxine's beaming, like the
Goddess of Nainai temple.
A cross between Storm, the
X-girl and Ahsoka Tano.
We love our laser eyes; our
Yoko granny glasses are dizzy.
Short women poets unite!
Revolution ain't just
style, it's destiny!
[ Laughter and Applause ]
Remember those spiral perms?
I don't know, you
guys are too young.
Oh, the spiral perms
in the 80s, you know.
I had-- ugh, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: It's been such a
pleasure to talk to you tonight.
Thank you so much.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh, thank you.
It's-- the hour's over.
I can't believe it.
>> Ron Charles: There
are poem books--
there are collections
for sale in the lobby.
Please fill out the
questionnaires and feel free
to come up and talk to Marilyn.
>> Marilyn Chin: Oh,
thank you so much.
Thank you [applause].
Thank you for coming.
Thank you.